[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mes chers amis quel immense joie d'être
ici ce soir à caen merci infiniment pour
votre présence et je voudrais vous dire
à quel point je suis touché que vous
soyez si nombreux ce soir vous avez pris
de votre temps certains d'entre vous ont
fait de la route pour être ici parmi
nous c'est une source d'encouragement
immense dans une campagne difficile
parfois même un peu éprouvante une
immense source d'encouragement de vous
savoir présent de vous savoir là partout
en france et de vous avoir aussi au
rendez vous dans ces grandes rencontres
qui commence pour cette nouvelle étape
de la campagne des européennes pour ses
trente quatre prochains jours qui nous
séparent du 26 mai merci infiniment de
votre présence à tous à tous merci
d'avoir pris de votre temps et je
voudrais saluer en particulier très
nombreux élus qui sont ici les nombreux
parlementaires je ne peux pas à tous les
citer parce qu'ils sont trop nombreux
c'est une vraie chance qu'il soit là
qu'il soit là pour nous entourer parce
qu'ils sont
vous êtes tous élus maires conseillers
départementaux conseillers régionaux
parlementaire la force de nos familles
politiques
la force de notre démocratie aussi est
dans un moment où vous l'avez dit
monsieur le président du sénat vous qui
savez mieux que personne
combien nos territoires sont fracturées
combien ils sont exposés à tant de
tension attendent fragilité aujourd'hui
ce sont nos élus locaux ce sont nos élus
de terrain qui font tenir la france
ensemble qui tiennent notre démocratie
et je crois que l'europe retrouvera son
sens qu'elle retrouvera sa consistance
si le mandat de parlementaire européen
est aussi un mandat d'élu local on peut
applaudir tous ensemble nos élus locaux
qui sont ici
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais remercier en particulier
ceux qui me font la joie d'être présent
avec qui nous avons passé cette journée
merci chers hervé de ta confiance de ta
présence qui me touche et qui m'honore
tu n'es pas tant le descendant de
guillaume le conquérant que le
préparateur des futures conquêtes et ça
n'est pas pour rien si notre campagne
européenne commence officiellement et se
lance ici en normandie dans cette terre
qui effectivement a plusieurs fois
marqué l'europe qui a été marqué par ce
que l'europe a vécu de pire et qu'il a
marqué pour le meilleur tout au long de
son histoire
merci infiniment de ton accueil merci de
ton soutien qui me touche infiniment
et puis cher gérard larcher nous avons
partagé une bien étrange soirée lundi
dernier nous étions à bois d'arcy dans
une salle bien plus petit dans un
département cher à mon coeur dans les
yvelines
au moment où nous voyons brûler notre
dame de paris
nous étions en réunion publique et nous
nous retrouvons ce soir dans un moment
peut-être plus plus heureux plus
souriant plus joyeux en tous les cas je
voudrais vous dire à quel point votre
confiance me touche aussi je sais
qu'elle n'était pas a gagné d'avancé
mais la confiance n'est jamais gagné
d'avancé et je sais et je le dis avec
une très profonde humilité que la
confiance qui m'a été témoignée par
toute notre famille politique il va me
falloir maintenant la mériter tout au
long de cette campagne dans les années
qui viendront en faisant de cette
confiance que vous m'offrez l'occasion
d'être utile au service de notre pays au
service de l'action que vous menez au
sénat et dont je voudrais vous remercier
de tout coeur parce que elle est
aujourd'hui nous l'avons dit le poumon
de notre démocratie de cet équilibre
démocratique dont nous avons tant besoin
je voudrais remercier en particulier le
sénateur philippe bas qui est parmi nous
et qui a fait ce travail de transparence
si nécessaire aujourd'hui
cette confiance cher laurent je sais que
c'est à toi que je la dois tu l'as dit
cette investiture n'était pas un choix
facile tu l'as fait c'était un pari je
vais tout faire pour que ce pari soit à
la hauteur de l'espérance que tu as mis
que notre mouvement miami je crois que
dans ce pari que tu as fait il y à
quelque chose comme le défi d'un
renouvellement qui ne soit pas celui de
la superficialité celui qui nous a
introduits disait que j'étais une tête
plus jeunes au milieu des têtes blanches
mais je me permettrai de faire cette
remarque toute simple que pour ma part
si je n'ai jamais été ma cronista c'est
d'abord parce que je n'ai jamais cru que
le nouveau monde et est forcément
meilleur que l'ancien et je crois que ce
qui fait la qualité
ce qui fait la qualité d'une action
politique ce qui fait la qualité d'une
action publique c'est toujours la
complémentarité entre ce que c'est vrai
il faut de renouvellement pour apporter
l'imagination et la créativité
nécessaire à l'action qui est menée au
service des citoyens mais aussi
l'expérience la compétence le sérieux
l'enracinement qui font ce qui nous lie
ce qui nous attachent les uns aux autres
et surtout ce qui nous permet de gagner
cette efficacité nécessaire fait
humilité indispensable pour pouvoir nous
mettre au service de ceux dont les
français ont réellement besoin et c'est
ce qui fait la qualité de la moindre de
nos équipes municipales dans la plus
petite commune de france c'est cette
complémentarité
c'est ce que je vis comme élu local
depuis dix ans et c'est aussi ce qui
fera j'espère l'efficacité de l'équipe
que nous formons dès aujourd'hui et je
voudrais remercier de tout coeur les
colistiers qui m'entourent dont vous
avez vu à quel point ils sont
remarquables à quel point déjà il
suscite l'enthousiasmé
anne-cécile merci de ta confiance
françoise pascal parce que c'est avec
vous avec toute notre liste avec arnaud
et agnès qui ne sont pas là ce soir
parce qu'ils sont partout ailleurs en
france pour aller parler à d'autres et
bien c'est avec vous que nous pourrons
être efficace tout au long des années
qui viennent je l'espère pour faire que
l'autre l'europe retrouve sa crédibilité
au service de tous les français
et puis enfin je voudrais remercier bien
sûr monsieur le maire joël bruneau qui
nous accueille
à tout seigneur tout honneur c'est vrai
que nous devions commencer à nîmes et
nous commençons à caen et je ne peux pas
ne pas m'empêcher d'y voir aussi
peut-être un signe du destin
car cette campagne européenne et cette
soirée que nous vivons nous la
partageons avec le coeur un peu et train
devant ce que nous avons vécu devant les
drames qui traversent encore notre monde
comme ils ont tant marqué votre ville
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
président il y a eu ce week-end cette
nouvelle terrible avec laquelle nous
nous sommes tous ces veillées de cet
attentat qui a marqué le sri-lanka des
dizaines de morts tués pour leur foi des
victimes innocentes qui ont été attaqués
et l'on sait aujourd'hui que cette
attaque a été revendiquée ce matin par
l'état islamique qui est l'ambassadeur
de la barbarie dans toutes les régions
du monde qu'il l'a été en france au
moyen-orient désormais au sri lanka et
qui porte cette idéologie qui voudraient
détruire non pas seulement notre
civilisation mais toute civilisation
pour la remplacer par cette culture de
la violence qui est profondément le
rejet de toute culture et tout ce contre
quoi nous combattons et donc c'est vrai
ce moment particulier que nous vivons
revêt une gravité singulière parce que
nous savons que nous avons devant nous
la tâche de lutter contre tout ce qui
menace tout ce à quoi nous tenons parce
que ces images de colombo ces images
d'église dévasté où la mort a frappé
font écho à cette autre image qui nous a
tous et train profondément qui nous a
tous hâte à l'image de notre dame de
paris en flammes au coeur de notre
capitale bien sûr il n'y a pas eu de
mort bien sûr les deux événements ne
saurait être comparée et par
l'extraordinaire engagement de nos
sapeurs pompiers nous avons la chance
d'avoir gardé dans cette tragédie
le souvenir d'un événement qui n'aura
pas fait de victimes et une cathédrale
qui malgré tout reste encore debout mais
au fond derrière cette expérience il y a
d'abord le signe d'un devoir adressé à
chacun d'entre nous aujourd'hui il nous
faut reconstruire et quand c'est plus
qu'aucune autre ville que le travail du
deuil est passée vient le temps de la
reconstruction la ville aux cent
clochers ou viollet le duc
qui travailla à notre dame de paris
avait un temps étudié la ville de
l'abbaye aux dames la ville si
directement éprouvées par les
bombardements de juin 44 équipes et ya
dans sa chair pour notre liberté
d'aujourd'hui
cette ville était sans doute le lieu
d'où finalement il fallait que nous
partions pour entreprendre ce travail si
nécessaire qui consiste à reconstruire
qui consiste à refonder à reposer les
fondations de l'europe pour nous
permettre de rétablir notre pays pour
rétablir la france c'est le devoir
celle de voir que nous avons devant nous
aujourd'hui et ce devoir il implique
fait vrai vous l'avez dit de sortir de
tous les simplismes de toutes les
facilités qu on voudrait nous imposer
non la question de l'europe n'est pas
d'abord une question d'idéologie
ça n'est pas une affaire de posture dans
ce débat depuis deux mois j'ai si
souvent entendu cette question un peu
étonné et je vous la renvoie puisque
vous êtes si nombreux ce soir mais
qu'est ce que vous venez faire ici
qu'est ce que vous venez faire dans ce
débat car ce débat il était c'est vrai
plié d'avancé c'était pour ou contre
c'était blanc ou noir cp gentil ou
méchant gentil progressiste contre
méchants populiste le monde est
tellement facile comme ça mais ça ne
correspond tellement pas au débat si
nécessaire que nous devons avoir
ensemble pour l'avenir de l'europe
car oui nous croyons que l'europe est
nécessaire pour relever tous les grands
défis de notre avenir
le défi économique et commerciale le
défi migratoire le défi écologique le
défi culturel qui est ballot moindre
d'entre eux mais oui nous croyons que
pour répondre à ces défis il faut
refonder l'europe et nous nous
contenterons pas d'une forme de
profession de foi qui parce que nous
croyons à l'europe voudrait laisser
passer tout ce qui a été manqué au cours
des dernières années dans le projet
européen
nous avons passé une journée
passionnante avec hervé morin
aujourd'hui une journée très
enrichissante au contact du terrain et
depuis deux mois et demi tous les jours
sur le terrain
c'est en rencontrant ce qu'ils vivent
ceux qui travaillent ceux qui agissent
ce qui crée du lien social ce qui
illustre le meilleur de notre culture de
nos savoir-faire de notre agriculture
c'est au contact de tous ceux qui vivent
sur le terrain les failles de l'europe
que je me laisse instruire pour pouvoir
tenir le discours le plus juste possible
sur l'europe dont nous avons besoin sur
la refondation européenne dont nous
avons besoin sur la question économique
commercial on le voit bien sûr nous
étions à l'instant avec des
représentants du monde des betteraviers
les betteraviers le savez vous sont
directement touchés par cette distorsion
de concurrence que nous avons nous mêmes
organisés au sein de l'espace européen
et entre l'europe et le reste du monde
distorsion de concurrence
si souvent motivées disons le par une
écologie devenu idéologie par une
écologie de posture qui a fini par créer
une europe de la double peine
cette europe de la double peine c'est
celle par laquelle nous nous interdisons
de produire en france
ce que d'autres pays peuvent produire en
europe dans laquelle nous nous
interdisons de produire en europe ce que
pourtant nous nous laissons importés en
europe et cette europe de la double
peine c'est celle qui fait qu'à la fin
des agriculteurs français des
industriels français qui travaillent
avec des normes de plus en plus
compliqué voit arriver sur le même
marché sur les mêmes étals de
supermarchés des produits venus
d'ailleurs cultiver sans aucune des
règles qu'on nous avait pourtant obliger
à respecter et dont on les avait chargé
cette europe de la double peine c'est
celle qui désespère aujourd'hui tant
d'entrepreneurs tant de chefs
d'entreprises tendent agriculteurs dans
notre pays c'est celle qui a enfermé
temps d'agriculteurs dans des impasses
économique qui les condamne au désespoir
et c'est celle qui finalement d'ailleurs
un site à la production infiniment moins
vertueux écologiquement que nous
voulions éviter
nous avons disons le l'agriculture qui
respecte les standards les plus élevés
au monde et tout ce que nous ferons pour
fragiliser cette agriculture française
nous le ferons contre l'écologie contre
l'idéal écologique contre le
rétablissement de cette équilibre du
monde dont nous avons tellement besoin
et c'est exactement malheureusement
derrière ce double discours que se joue
aujourd'hui on l'a dit la liste
de la république en marche qui
effectivement ne cesse de promouvoir ne
serait ce que dans sa deuxième place
ceux qui se sont faits au cours des
dernières années les porte parole d'une
écologie qui regardent l'agriculture
comme suspecte les agriculteurs comme
des délinquants qu'il faudrait contrôler
et finalement qu'il faudrait parvenir
d'une certaine manière à faire abdiquer
à leur désir de nourrir et d'alimenter
d'autres pays que nous même de continuer
à promouvoir une agriculture qui rayonne
c'est cette idéologie là qui est promu
derrière madame l'oiseau sur la liste de
la république en marche on pourra faire
le casting qu'on veut on pourra afficher
le visage qu'on voudra la réalité des
faits est là et il faut avoir dans ce
débat une clarté indispensable parce que
cette clarté nous la devons à ces
agriculteurs désespérés nous la devons à
ces chefs d'entreprise qui peinent
malgré tout leur travail et tous leurs
efforts
cette clarté nous la devons aussi au
monde qui se dessine
parce que si nous voulons une véritable
écologie pragmatique intelligente une
écologie respectueuse de ceux qui
travaillent une écologie qui parviennent
à produire les effets qu'elle prétend
produire alors nous devons absolument
renoncer à ces postures renoncer à ces
simplisme et c'est ce que nous proposons
bien sûr avec le projet des républicains
nous proposons
nous proposons de faire de ce marché
unique l'occasion d'une immense force
dans le combat pour relever le défi
écologique nous proposons de faire de ce
marché unique l'occasion d'un nouvel
équilibre dans la mondialisation dont
nous avons tellement besoin
il faut créer une barrière écologique
il faut créer une frontière intelligente
à l'entrée du marché unique européen qui
nous permettent de faire en sorte que
ceux qui importent leurs produits en
europe respecte les mêmes règles que
ceux qui produisent en europe qu'ils
payent la contribution carbone que paye
ce qu'ils produisent en europe qu'ils
payent aussi pour la complexité et
qu'ils assument cette complexité des
normes que nous imposons à ceux qui
produisent en europe parce que sinon
nous allons continuer à produire cette
europe de la double peine et à
entretenir ce déséquilibre du monde dans
lequel nous sommes
le saviez vous il n'ya non cet exemple
tout simple
prenons cet exemple tout simple qui
parlera dans cette région où la pêche
joue un rôle si important
on y reviendra le saviez vous il n'ya en
europe quasiment plus aucune capacité de
traitement du poisson c'est un exemple
que je prends souvent mais bien parlants
pour comprendre ce qui est en question
quasiment plus aucune capacité de
traitement du poisson pour le dire
autrement un poisson qui est pêché dans
les eaux européennes
s'il doit être traité pour être
consommée sous forme de plats préparés
et bien on va l'emmener généralement en
asie en chine pour être traité et
ensuite on le ramènera en europe pour
être consommés avant d'arriver dans
votre assiette un poisson préparé a fait
des milliers de kilomètres
il a fait des milliers de kilomètres et
il est vendu sur les étals
comme si ils venaient du pêcheur juste à
côté
et ensuite on explique à l'ouvrier
français aux salariés français à
l'artisan français qui a besoin de sa
voiture pour faire 10 km pour aller
travailler que c'est lui qui est
responsable du dérèglement climatique et
que c'est sur lui qu'on va faire peser
une taxation toujours plus lourdes
une taxation qui n'est que l'autre nom
de la capacité de notre pays à se
réformer en profondeur pour retrouver
l'oxygène dont il a besoin pour
permettre à ceux qui travaillent de
gagner vraiment ce que leur travail
devrait permettre de mériter et donc il
y a aujourd'hui évidemment pour l'europe
un défi magnifique un défi fondamental
qui est celui de redonner un équilibre à
la mondialisation
nous ne pouvons plus vivre dans cette
mondialisation débridée qui a conduit à
une forme de terrorisme international de
répartition des tâches à l'échelle
globale où on a pu croire pendant
quelques temps que l'asie allait faire
l'industrie et que nous allions vivre
des services et des loisirs
ça ne peut pas fonctionner et c'est
cette vision du monde où cette absence
de vision qui a produit la catastrophe
économique et sociale que nous
connaissons mais c'est aussi celle là
qui produit le déséquilibre écologique
que nous déplorons alors oui si nous
voulons être à la hauteur de ce défi
écologique il nous faut sortir de
l'idéologie et réconcilier économie et
écologie pour faire en sorte de
réapprendre à produire ce que nous
consommons et pour faire que le marché
européen devienne ce magnifique poumon
dont nous avons besoin pour le monde de
demain
redonner
redonner un équilibre à la
mondialisation c'est aussi bien sûr
c'est aussi bien sûr faire face aux
défis migratoires
le défi migratoire n'est pas derrière
nous comme on l'entend trop souvent le
défi migratoire est devant nous la crise
migratoire n'a pas encore commencé je le
dis à dessein dans une terre qui elle
aussi il sait ce que veut dire la
réalité de ces flux migratoires lorsque
nous ne parvenons pas à maîtriser nos
frontières la réalité de ces flux
migratoires c'est du malheur à grande
échelle malheur pour nos sociétés bien
sûr déchiré déjà partant de
communautarisme valeur pour nos sociétés
dans lesquelles nous ne savons pas
aujourd'hui intégré tant de ces jeunes
qui sont issus d'une immigration plus ou
moins récentes et qui pourtant nés en
france ne se reconnaissent pas dans la
france parce que une immigration entre
massive les a piégés dans leur
communauté d'origine malheur pour nos
sociétés dont gérard collomb qui n'est
pas un activiste d'extrême droite nous a
averti qu' aujourd'hui si nous vivons
côte à côte
demain nous pourrions bien vivre face à
face il faut faire quelque chose bien
sûr de cet avertissement qui nous est
envoyée tous les jours partant
d'enseignants quant aux territoires
perdus de la république
envoyez tous les jours par tant de mer
par tant d'élus locaux qui nous alerte
sur le fait que le grand défi pour nous
est aujourd'hui d'intégrer d'assimiler
de faire en sorte que chacun partage une
même culture commune
nous n'avons pas le droit dans cette
situation d'extrême fragilité
nous n'avons pas le droit de nous
résigner à notre impuissance en matière
de maîtrise des flux migratoires mais
malheur aussi à grande échelle pour tous
ces jeunes venus d'afrique auquel les
passeurs tendent le miroir aux alouettes
d'une prospérité qu'ils ne trouveront
pas en arrivant en europe
qui peut croire sérieusement qui parmi
vous peut croire lorsqu'ils voient comme
nous les avons vu aujourd'hui ces jeunes
venus d'afrique qui se retrouvent
piégées dans l'impasse des ports
normands espérant passer en angleterre
coincé dans ce piège mortel qui leur a
été tendue par des négociants sans
scrupules qui les rackettent pour leur
faire traverser au risque de leur vie la
mer méditerranée
tout cela ne prospère que sur une seule
condition tout cela prospère sur notre
impuissance et à tous les beaux discours
je me souviens je me souviens bien sûr
d'une campagne présidentielle dans
laquelle monsieur macron nous expliquer
qu'il y avait deux camps c'est toujours
très simple au fond le camp de
l'ouverture le camp de la fermeture le
camp des gentils et des méchants vous
avez retenu la leçon il y avait les
gentils qui était pour l'ouverture et
c'était eux il y avait les méchants qui
était pour la fermeture et c'était vous
bien sûr bref ceux qui croient qu'il
faut des murs mais bien sûr qu'il faut
que nous puissions maîtriser nos
frontières ne serait ce que pour
accueillir ceux qui ont vraiment besoin
de notre solidarité pour pouvoir ouvrir
la porte et faire entrer celui qui a
besoin de trouver chez nous l'occasion
d'un foyer où il pourra être accueilli
comme il se doit et bien encore faut-il
avoir une porte encore faut-il avoir un
foyer et donc nous défendons bien sûr
dans cette campagne européenne
nous défendons la nécessité pour
l'europe de maîtriser ses frontières et
la nécessité pour l'europe de permettre
à chacun des états de maîtriser sa
politique migratoire
c'est ce que nous appelons le principe
de la double frontières il faut une
politique européenne pour défendre
ensemble nos frontières car qui peut
croire sérieusement que chacun des états
européens seul sera plus fort face à ce
défi qui peut croire sérieusement que la
grèce sera suffisamment forte pour
pouvoir relever ce défi tout seul qui ne
voient que comme vous le disiez à
l'instant monsieur le président c'est
évidemment aujourd'hui quand l'italie
ferme ses portes par l'espagne que
passent les migrants pour le dire
autrement il faut une stratégie
européenne pour défendre ensemble de
frontières et nous ne sommes pas de ceux
qui comme le rassemblement national ont
décidé par pure idéologie eux aussi que
tout ce qui vient de l'europe était
mauvais y compris quand ça nous renforce
nous ne sommes pas de ceux qui comme le
rassemblement national ont voté au cours
des dernières années contre tous ceux
qui pouvaient nous renforcer dans la
lutte contre le défi migratoire contre
tout ce qui pouvait nous permettre de
maîtriser mieux nos frontières le
rassemblement national nous dit on
arrive mais le rassemblement national à
un bilan ils sont là déjà au parlement
européen ils ont gagné la dernière
élection européenne etc ont-ils fait
pendant cinq ans
ils ont voté contre l'établissement des
contrôles systématiques aux frontières
extérieures de l'europe
ils ont voté contre le renforcement de
frontex qui lui contre l'immigration
illégale
ils ont voté contre le pnr qui permet de
connaître ceux qui volent dans le ciel
européen contre tout ce qui était
demandé par nos services de police de
gendarmerie de renseignements pour nous
permettre de mieux maîtriser
l'entrée sur le territoire européen par
pure idéologie
eh bien nous ne sommes pas de ceux qui
par posture par idéologie fragilise nos
pays au lieu de les renforcer
redonner un équilibre à la
mondialisation c'est évidemment faire en
sorte que l'europe puisse maîtriser ses
frontières pour préserver la sécurité et
la paix du monde de demain et pour faire
en sorte que l'afrique puisse se
développer au lieu d'être vidé de ses
forces vives par notre inconséquence et
parfois même d'ailleurs disons le par
une forme de cynisme et enfin bien sûr
il y à ce grand défi qui est devant nous
et qui est le défier le pouvoir rpt dire
qui nous sommes
quel drame qu'il ait fallu voir brûler
notre dame de paris pour que nous nous
sentions tous étreint par une certitude
désormais incontestable nous sommes liés
les uns aux autres par une histoire qui
nous précèdent et cette histoire fait
qui nous sommes cette histoire c'est
nous
j'ai trouvé magnifique car au fond dans
le mal parfois il y à l'occasion de
redécouvrir un bien et j'ai trouvé
magnifique que nous ayons tous étaient
simultanément et reins le coeur retourné
l'âme atteintes par ces images d'une
cathédrale qui brûle ça n'avait rien
d'une évidence pour notre époque offerte
aux calculs et qui pourrait croire que
tout se résume à la question de ce qui
se rationalisent de ce qui pèse dans une
équation de ceux qui compte de ce qu'ils
rapportent
au fond il y a dans le fait que nous
ayons perdu là quelque chose
d'incalculables il y à là quelque chose
qui ne peut que susciter en nous une
très profonde espérance
oui
nous sommes liés les uns aux autres par
quelque chose qui nous précèdent et qui
nous dépasse infiniment
quand j'ai lu la lettre d' emmanuel
macron adressé aux européens j'ai été
très frappé de voir que monsieur macron
de parle de l'europe que comme d'un
projet mais l'europe n'est pas seulement
un projet l'europe c'est une
civilisation
l'europe c'est un héritage l'europe
c'est une histoire et nous avons besoin
de re dire qui nous sommes pour nous
projeter dans l'avenir
l'europe c'est ce petit miracle de la
liberté qui naît dans les cités grecques
lorsque le développement de la raison
critique au vème siècle avant
jésus-christ donne naissance à la
démocratie l'europe c'est le sens de
l'égalité devant la res publica la chose
de tous qui se déploie dans la loi
romaine et qui se déploient partout
d'ailleurs sur le continent européen
à travers la culture latine l'europe
c'est aussi bien sûr pourquoi ne pas le
dire pourquoi ne pas le reconnaître
pourquoi ne pas se rendre compte de
cette évidence intime
l'europe c'est aussi bien sur cet
héritage judéo-chrétien cette tradition
chrétienne qui a fait mûrir petit à
petit pendant des siècles le sens de la
dignité humaine
et que tout ce que tous nous ayons tous
été touchés croyants ou non croyants
chrétiens ou non chrétiens bien sûr que
tous nous ayons tous été touchés de la
gauche à la droite de notre vie
politique a été je crois l'occasion pour
nous de se rendre compte par les fai qui
venait infligé un démenti cinglant à
notre déni de réalité que oui c'est vrai
nous avons fait une grande erreur en
refusant de dire dans nos traités qui
nous sommes en refusant de nommer dans
les traités européens
les racines de notre europe l'europe
n'est pas une organisation
internationale comme une autre l'europe
c'est un méritas et simon ne savons pas
dire qui nous sommes
comment pourrons-nous relever le défi de
l'intégration je les ai vécus comme
enseignant comment pourrons nous faire
en sorte que ces jeunes qui grandissent
aujourd'hui en france soit capable de se
reconnaître de la france si nous ne
savons pas leur dire à quel héritage ils
peuvent participer
quelle histoire ils peuvent continuer
quel élan rejoindre dire qui nous sommes
savoir nommer nos racines ça n'est pas
du tout anecdotique
emmanuel macron dans un grand discours
qu'il a prononcé au bernardin a dit vous
savez moi le débat sur les racines de
l'europe ça ne m'intéresse pas ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la sève et pas les
racines
ce qui m'intéresse dit en substance
emmanuel macron c'est le nouveau monde
et pas l'ancien ce qui m'intéresse c'est
l'avenir et pas le passé mais qui peut
croire sérieusement qu'on peut
construire l'avenir en se détournant du
passé et quelle personne qui a planté un
jour un arbre dans sa vie peut croire
qu'on peut espérer avoir de la sève si
on n'a pas d'abord des racines
alors oui c'est vrai c'est ce qui nous
unit c'est ce qui nous unit aujourd'hui
dans ce débat européen c'est ce qui fait
que nous sommes rassemblés pour pouvoir
porter cette europe que nous voulons
rassembler depuis le premier jour avec
agnès evren avec arnaud danjean depuis
la constitution de cette liste qui
représente tous les territoires de notre
pays toutes les sensibilités toutes les
générations
rassemblés pour dire que nous avons
besoin de refonder l'europe de reposer
l'europe sur ses fondations pour pouvoir
rétablir la france depuis deux mois et
demi nous faisons campagne avec un
projet clair approuvée à l'unanimité par
notre famille politique
grâce à guillaume larrivé qui a fait ce
travail immense de constituer ce projet
pendant des mois nous avons un projet il
m'arrive parfois un journaliste qui est
ici présent d'ailleurs ce matin me
disais meilleur quels sont vos
différences avec le projet dans marche
et bien c'est très simple la grande
différence c'est que nous avons un
projet
on nous a on nous a présenté emmanuel
macron comme un grand européen mais nous
avons le sentiment aujourd'hui un peu
triste et je le déplore
nous avons le sentiment que tout est
fait pour tuer ce débat européen auquel
nous voulons contribuer parce que oui
vous avez le choix et vous devez savoir
le choix que vous avez et vous devez
pouvoir faire le 26 mai un vrai choix
non pas pour l'europe qu'on voudrait
vous imposer mais pour l'europe que vous
voulez nous le savons ici nous l'avons
vu aujourd'hui le break sites dont
certains se sont réjouies et le signe de
cette défiance qui monte partout en
europe
et si nous ne savons pas répondre à
cette défiance alors l'europe se
disloquera le break si tu n'es pas dans
les piscines un épiphénomène je le vois
depuis le début de cette campagne
cette défiance là nous n'allons pas la
résoudre en disant que nous sommes pour
l'europe
nous n'allons pas la résoudre en
proclamant de grands mots nous la
résoudrons quand nous mettant patiemment
humblement à l'écouté des français qu'en
sortant de ce débat stérile pour
proposer aux français un vrai choix
monsieur bardella est entrée dans ses
campagnes en disant que son grand rêve
le 26 mai c'était de voir pleurer les
représentants dans marche et madame le
madame l'oiseau est rentré dans cette
campagne en disant que son grand rêve
c'était son premier discours c'était de
battre madame le pen au fond on a le
sentiment que beaucoup cherchent à faire
de ce débat européen l'occasion d'un
grand moment politiciens mais nous
voulons un vrai moment politique
nous n'avons qu'un seul rêve dans ce
débat c'est de nous intéresser aux
problèmes des français et de tenter de
résoudre les problèmes des français
c'est de faire en sorte
c'est de faire en sorte que cette
volonté de défaire l'europe n'est plus
de nourriture possible qu'elle ne se
fondent plus rien et que l'europe
retrouve la confiance des citoyens en
étant de nouveau efficace à leurs
services au quotidien et c'est dans
cette perspective que nous sommes
rassemblés autour de ce projet et au
fond ce que nous sommes ici venu dire
c'est la force de ce rassemblement de ce
rassemblement avec les centristes et
cher hervé de ce rassemblement autour de
la reconstruction de la droite que tu
mènes cher laurent pour pouvoir faire en
sorte que demain la france qui a besoin
de se rétablir trouve derrière elle des
parlementaires européens efficaces et
capables de l'appuyer une europe forte
et capable de soutenir chacun de nos
états dans la mondialisation que la
france puisse ainsi trouvé l'occasion de
se rétablir c'est notre immense
espérance et nous allons la construire
ensemble
grâce à votre travail à votre effort
grâce à la victoire que vous allez
obtenir parce que chacun d'entre vous
jouera un rôle décisif
chacune de vos voix comptera nous avons
34 jours devant nous trente quatre jours
pour convaincre pour ramener à nous ceux
qui doutent ceux qui sont défiants ceux
qui sont critiques
ceux qui ne veulent plus y croire trente
quatre jours pour leur dire que nous
pouvons y croire encore que nous devons
y croire encore parce que notre avenir
en dépend
une partie de notre avenir se joue dans
ces 34 jours et je compte sur vous pour
faire en sorte que dans trente quatre
jours nous ayons une belle victoire qui
déjoue tous les pronostics et qui nous
offre l'élan nécessaire pour refonder
l'europe et pour rétablir la france
merci encore